yeah I first heard of Paul because he
was he's a board of trustee at the
commune History Museum and then lo he's
the CTO of Accenture and I've been
getting to know Paul and I found out he
you know he started out as a programmer
software engineer went on to become a
computer science center the ph.d program
took a little time out at Accenture and
bang thirty years later you're still
there I think you and Earth's may be the
only two people in this facility that
have never worked anywhere else but
where you're currently working outside
of academia tell me how did that happen
yeah well you know I got into it first I
was at the University of Michigan and
one day I vividly remember the day when
some Lisa computers showed up on campus
and I saw those and said this is what
I'm gonna do you know got hooked on
hooked on software and computers at that
point now is going to go into a ph.d
program as I talked to you about and I
had a mentor that said you'll get one
year of business experience before you
get your PhD and I very strategically
went to the placement office and went
down the list and start in the A's and I
worked for Accenture and I thought it'd
be one year of a coding COBOL and being
miserable with with that and then going
back to the ph.d program I showed up on
my first project which was a driver
licensing system for a state government
in the US and COBOL imsd BDC my worst
nightmares realized and I worked I had a
smart group of folks that's working with
it came up with an approach to say let's
not code this thing let's model it in
the small talk as objects and let's it's
generate the schemas for the database
and generate the COBOL code and it'll be
you know verifiable and you know be a
better way of doing it and we did that
and it just turned me on to this idea
but we can use very innovative and I was
1986 you know very use very innovative
technologies like small talk even at
that stage to solve real-world problems
and bring innovation to results close
together and got hooked on it and I'm
still here now like lucky Accenture so
so 30 years I mean you've seen a lot of
transitions in technology you know so so
where would you put cloud in that what
was the tipping point and also when the
you at Accenture decide Accenture should
embrace the cloud and start building
solutions yeah I mean it's for me it's
it's economics if you look at economics
you can figure out what's gonna happen
and you indoors and others talked about
this already this morning but the you
know we had a fundamental belief going
back almost 20 years ago that compute
storage and network costs we're gonna go
to zero absolute article ii approaches
zero and that's that's what's happening
and we believe that as that happened
you'd have things like the cloud
happening even though we didn't call it
cloud at that point and would have
things like iot happening because now
there's centralized for power or you
distribute you know with with small
devices at the edge and so we've been
investing in driving you know in that
direction for a long period of time and
then about 2008 we looked at it and said
there's there's a big commercial
business you know around this that we
conform and you can see the slide up
there i think that talks about the
evolutionary technology that you and i
talked about diane and what we saw was
you know the ability to really form a
big business around clouds so we
launched a strategic initiative around
2008 so let's get serious about this and
that's growing into being one of the
most you know biggest most successful
parts of Accenture which is our cloud
business over 30,000 people twenty
thousand projects completed and driving
cloud and then about two years ago we
saw this pivot I think that you know
many in the audience had probably seen
him that some of the speakers have
talked about today where we believed
about two years ago we saw that public
cloud first was the way to go we started
shifting our focus we had been doing a
lot of public cloud work we said that's
the way to start and let's just use that
as a starting point and we've been
driving on that a map mission for about
two years and that gets us to where we
are today but the important thing I
think and where it comes to Google is is
the cloud is really a starting point in
our view and you can see all the waves
of innovation that are happening and
what that means for business people
running businesses is you need a
platform where you can innovate faster
and all the innovations the machine
learning artificial intelligence and
innovations to come are why you need the
cloud as the foundation because no
business can innovate fast enough on
their own without tapping into the power
of a cloud like what we've put together
getting the data getting the mobile
access bringing it all together right
it's a big deal yeah a big deal is a big
challenge for the enterprises to do it
enough given the pace of Technology
right all right and the other thing I
you know I was talking about today is
sort of getting into this sort of
exponential curve of having impact and
how we feel working with our partners
working with our customers were now able
to do that and you know we've been in
the cloud for over 16 years but it's you
know I mentioned as you were coming out
that we're now announcing a partnership
where we're going to bring solutions to
our customers can you tell me a little
bit about that yeah no we're very
excited about the partnership that you
know I've been working on and you know
for me it's our business is about
bringing innovation to customers to help
them transform their businesses for the
digital economy and when we look across
everything you've talked about laid out
and you know my compliments on the wave
laid out the story it's really fantastic
true yeah and it's real and we see a
tremendous opportunity to bring all that
technology together collectively to
really help transform business and
that's the fundamentally what we're
doing through the partnership we
announced so whether you looking at you
know Google cloud you look at apps the
analytics look at ml at Android Chrome
Maps you know all the pieces together
tango yeah there's you look at the
transformative power to business that's
what excites us and so we formed the
partnership and we've long we're
launching at Accenture and Google joint
Innovation Center to bring things to
life for customers we're forming
extension Google Joint Center of
Excellence to build those solutions and
develop solutions and we're focusing on
a set of a set of solutions and products
that will help clients construct better
digital experiences will help transform
the digital culture within their
organizations and then bring better
digital tools to help imagine their
business and it's very exciting any
specific examples I mean I think it's so
cool that you're doing both Android and
the cloud and the apps you know when
this sort of broad array the machine
yeah there's a number of great great
examples I get really excited about one
of the ones I get perfectly excited
about is something we're calling retail
trend watcher and retail trend watcher
is it combines some unique IP of
research we've done around something
called the customer genome which is a
unique unique way of understanding the
customer and we were putting that
in the Google cloud and then we're
combining a lot of other capabilities
we're tying in the vision API so that we
can do things like go to Pinterest and
find images and pictures and categorize
the you know get the product item
product classifications and things then
we're adding the natural language API so
we can go to Facebook and find customer
comments and sentiment and those sorts
of things then you put that all together
with the the ml you know machine
learning the API to do the new neural
modeling - then do forecasting and trend
prediction of what's gonna happen going
forward we think this is just a
transformative tool set now a great
solution for retail customers we're
gonna give you an honorary PhD for doing
this I could use one of those things No
so so another interesting thing I
learned about you is you've been really
paying attention to the trends in the
workplace you know we saw with Airbus
you know here they were analyzing these
satellite images with people by hand
that a long time took a lot of people
and then they applied machine learning
and it really didn't take so many people
or very long anymore some people are
kind of saying the workplace is getting
disrupted I know you talked about that
at the World Economic Forum and you
really take a very optimistic view
I actually share it I wonder if you
could talk a little bit about that I'll
just give you that the summary and I
starting it by saying that we have I
agree with some others who have said
today that artificial intelligence is
the big thing that's gonna transform
business over the next 20 years bigger
than anything you know anything else
we've seen and the way we've done
business in the 20th century which is
the way most of us are still doing
business just isn't gonna work anymore
going forward so we have this tremendous
transformation of business powered by
cloud and powered by the innovation that
we're talking about and that's certainly
going to create a lot of disruption but
it's really gonna create growth and we
just released a study yesterday that's
out there available on our website where
we did as a modeling of what the
economic impact of AI isn't a business
impact and what we what we showed with
this study is that we believe that
there'll be a potential doubling of GDP
which in the u.s. would mean a growth
from two-and-a-half percent to four and
a half percent roughly which could be
eight trillion dollars of added economic
I'll put in the economy if the potential
of AI is realized similar results in
Japan and Germany and most other
countries you looked at and the
underlying reason for that is that we
believe a I drives increased
productivity of up to 40% for
individuals and people in humans
depending on the jobs you doing because
it's people plus the technology coming
together a lot of people to do what they
do best more effectively so we believe
it's a tremendous story it's it creates
economic growth it creates growth for
businesses growth for economies and
better opportunities for people going
forward and it's good that we're
teaching every kindergartner how to
program so that as they get up there all
people will be participating will be
better that's that's a big thing don't
do the right things from an education
perspective and it needs to start early
then we won't have the workforce
prepared well so that really is critical
room involved a lot of initiatives to
make sure that's the case but we
definitely don't have enough people to
very opportunity rich world we're living
in it's very exciting okay well good
thanks a lot Paul this is great thanks
time